10月6號,OpenAI一口氣公開了一大批AI做出來的數學新結果。
兩天後,一位菲爾茲獎得主在線上講座說,
他寫進論文、演講跟經費申請的研究題目全部被解掉了,議題不慎。
如你能想像,
我每三天都必須重新思考我的表演,
尤其是昨天。
講話的人叫Hugo-Dominio Copin,2022年的菲爾茲獎得主,
在法國高等科學研究所跟日內瓦大學當教授。
他研究的是滲流,一塊滿是小孔的石頭,孔多到某個程度,水會突然從滲不過去,變成整塊流的通。
這場是法國數學學會10月8號開的線上講座,他講第一場。
我一直在討論,不知是否是5.5、5.6,
但是又是一個新的ChatsGPT。
為了給大家與我的尋找有關的故事,
我一位同事,開玩笑的說,
這是他生命中第一次接觸LM,
他接觸了他工作的問題。
我工作了十多年,
我有一份70頁的DUKE文章,
展示了4比4的大小。
這位同事在前一年成功展示了2比2的大小。
他開玩笑地說:"我會放在GPT的調查中,
你能做到嗎?"
這是他真正的解釋,
由Benjamini和Shram所說的解釋,
Chadjipiti給他出了一個非常美麗的一頁證據,
我們不可以說他只是去尋找正確的證據在一個我們不認識的文件中。
所以,
這位年輕人的震驚和他在過去一分鐘的年紀中工作的問題並沒有太大影響,
是否證據簡單還是不簡單,
證據很美麗,很短的。
所以我們說,
很明顯,
結束了,
這兩個月,兩個月的故事。
後來,
我們答應了,
因為在5月份,
有了阿爾道士問題,
我們仍然認識了
亞美聯合協會
確實變得厲害,
但也許
可能不符合我們的專業的研究能力
所以在這兩個情況下
我們看到有一個長距離的邏輯
有一個連接失去了
但當這個連接被發現了
證據本身並沒有那麼複雜
所以這就是專業的知識和專業的理論能力
他這一行有一道猜想
寫作Feta PC等於零
他問的是
恐剛好多到零界點的那一刻
水到底流不流得過去
三維空間的版本
幾十年來沒有人證得出來
我自己的經驗是
最初的
最後的
大致上,我們聽到一些謠言,
除了謠言之外,
最大的謠言,至少最有名的謠言,
叫做tetaPC-0,
被眾所知解決了。
我們只是聽到謠言,
並沒有任何直接的資訊。
如果有接觸的人,就算沒有接觸,也沒有發佈信息,
所以我們完全被黑暗地看著。
2月2日,我們發現了一個Lin證,沒有任何信息。
我對於電腦有些困難的人來說,
和我的電腦,所以我坦白說,我已經兩次的年齡了,
我甚至不懂得我正在看的東西,
也就是說,我的同事必須使用自己的電子智能,
以轉換這個Lin的證據,
成為一個完全不可理解的文章。
我非常欣賞一些我們的年輕同事們的努力去讀這些很糟糕的文章,
他們現在正在重新寫作,
例如今天阿爾汀發表了一個比較短的廣泛的文章,
但我們對這方面的廣泛解釋有很大的努力。
因此,
我們認為這些問題在我們的職業中是最大的問題。
這就是我們的目標,我們共同尋找的方案。
這問題已經解決了。
六天後,我們決定不再通知這些新聞。
我們沒有那麼想要媒體的披露
但是6天后,納維斯托克斯被證明了
你們都經歷過這種情況
總之,他被證明了
所以所有媒體都懷疑了這件事
因為媒體反應了我們過去所要求的方式
比如看一條《迷連尼羅姆》問題
或一條《菲律斯級大獎》問題
在這方面,《OpenAI》就有了異例的發現
所以這很像是一個各種媒體的變化
但是我必須說,我必須說,我必須說,
悲傷在社區上已經有了進一步的影響
不幸的是,
我對中秋節的事實是很嚴重的
但是事情已經變得更嚴重了
因為有兩天,你們都知道
這三百五十個問題都被證明了。
這是一個很大的問題。
我認為很多人都很高興能夠證明這些問題。
基本上,這就是我最後的幾個月。
有點擔心,有點驚訝。
這就是我週末晚上的一天。
我放了幾個車輛,因為我只是想給大家看一看壞壞的程度。
所有這些問題,我所提到的問題在我的展覽中,
在我的文章中,在我的財務要求中,
過去和未來,坦白說。
他們都被解決了。
沒有一個沒有被解決。
因此,我遇到一個相當不新的情況,
就是所有的搜尋領域,
對我來說是不新的,
所有我的搜尋領域都被解決了。
有很多搜尋領域都被解決了。
例如,我們遇到的搜尋領域有六張紙,
整個領域有超過六百頁的紙,
為了適合搜尋領域的搜尋領域。
這項搜尋領域是我們很好的項目,
但似乎我們比預料的更遠,不然我們會找到更短的證據。
但是,
六百頁,
我認為很多人聽過很多人已經看過我的展覽,
他們可能聽過這些問題。
我上星期晚上開了一篇文章,我在那裡,我不明白這篇文章。
9月11號
25位菲爾茲獎得主
發了一封聯名信
說AI公司
搶著拿數學難題當跑分
正在傷害數學
這場講座的標題
就是那封信的標題
後面再補上28天后
在這些問題上,我並不定義自己作為一個人工智能工程師,
我定義自己作為一個人工智能工程師不使用的人工智能工程師,
但我並沒有任何問題,因為在某些情況下,它是完全適合的。
但相反,大企業和一些我們的同事們所使用的智能工程師,
並不是所有人都使用的智能工程師,我認為是完全不適合的。
這個討論的主題是我們第一次在小組裡面討論的討論,
然後我們邀請了所有的優秀獎項目來與這個討論聯繫。
我們討論的討論是關於這件事,
這種問題,就是人工智能的使用,
尤其是與人們玩電視遊戲的費用,
它只是用來系統性地破壞問題
在4月份,我發現一個人試圖與我聯繫
這位人很明顯地告訴我
他自己選擇的電腦,當然是他自己選擇的計劃
什麼問題會被解決,根據我們的計劃
當然,我們有更多的知識,
但是我們在研發數學的全面自動化中。
堅定地發現,
影響被限制了,
我認為這可能幫助了社區聯合發表聲明。
聯合公司影響,
就像昨天的宣告一樣,
我們都看到了這件事。
更重要的是,
這件事並沒有破壞所有開放的建築物,
這件事並沒有被聽到。
我們必須證明,
他們能夠在最深入的角度上殺死我們。
我認為,
但我認為我們沒有任何人在納維斯托克選舉之後
不認為他們能夠做到這種東西
我們未來可以討論的事情並不是緊急的
而是關於我們現在的年輕人的事情
我的課程和職業課程的各個學生都在悲慘狀態中
我理解他們的狀況
學歷、職業、職業的學生也會有這些問題。
簡單地說,這是研究研究的未來嗎?
還有三個我喜歡做的問題。
一個重要的問題是,
我認為我們有一個聯繫和情報的聯繫問題。
也就是說,這些公司喜歡Buzz,
並且強化了他們的活動和交流的這一層面。
這對於我來說,對於那些對我來說感到很難過的人,
不知道他們會否知道,
在下午上的時間裡,這將會變得更嚴重。
這是一種地獄。
有個記者給我聯絡,
所以我知道這將會發生。
我們首先給了我一個時間,
但其實那不是這個時間,
這三次都被重新調整了。
這是一個很不可思議的壓力。
我們可以解決數學問題
但我們可以看我們的做法
我們的發言方式
我必須說我們也不可否認
今年夏天
他寫了一篇短文談AI跟數學
自認寫得很節制
結果收到一堆措辭很兇的信
寄信的還是科學家
在這篇文章中,
我悔恨地寫了一篇文章在我自己的創作過程中,
我並沒有在私人上使用人工智能。
這是我使用的人工智能的一句話。
我立即被定義了。
當然,我可以保證,自從我的同事們寫了這篇文章後,
我可以保證,公眾和公眾組織都使用了這篇文章,
以作為人工智能的抵抗,因為我做了這些事情。
我仍然要提醒大家,我只說了,我對於人工智能的用戶,我並沒有使用。
我們正在一個關鍵的過程中。
我現在就結束了,因為我沒有學到我的錯誤。
我將結束了,我將告訴大家我對於人工智能的用戶的做法。
這樣,我將能夠強化人們認為自己是人工智能。
當然,我將嘗試了這幾十個證據的證據。
只是為了給大家一個理解,在Openeye發佈的文章中,
如果我們直接寫出我自己的評論,有3500頁。
我在我整個人的生活中發佈了3700頁,
所以我必須把這些評論並解釋,
除非我所寫的東西並不代表我特別有興趣的東西。
這幾乎代表了我本來想做的幾乎一半的文章和問題
有很多是我未來想做的東西
或者是我之前工作過的東西
但我並沒有能夠發揮出足夠有趣或重要的東西
以使它能夠在OpenAI的工作中被提供
所以 明白所有這些東西
會是一個組織的事情
當然 和我的同事們
我們的目的就是嘗試在這些結果上
在我的情況下,我繼續在自己身上尋找,並沒有在社交媒體上的幫助。
在我的公共交流中,
我認為我所傳輸的更多是一個能夠理解困難的問題,
一個能夠討論它們,如何管理我的情緒等等。
我可以保證你,16歲的孩子沒有任何的自我避免行動或迫害。
但在研究和解決這些問題的基礎上,
我認為在聯繫中,
我們帶來更多的學習證據,
甚至是我們所理解的證據。
坦白說,我們必須理解這些證據。
但我認為,除此之外,
數學也是人類的科學,
也就是人類研究人類的研究項目。
在目前的情況下,
這就是人類能夠隱秘,
能夠與艱難的問題討論,
能夠超越自己的意識,
等等,
等等。
第三點,就是增強科學中的參與和公眾和學生的努力。
這對所有人來說是一個緊張的手段。
我認為在華語大學裡的研究時間很短
如果我們想幫助社會,我們必須努力
我並不說大家必須看到11歲的學生
這並不是最簡單的事情
但有很多可能和想象的科技聯繫活動
增加教育的用途
是肯定我會花更多時間在教育中
整個研究方向一次被清空之後
Dominio Copping打算先把那幾千頁讀懂
然後不靠AI繼續自己想
他想傳下去的是人自己想通一道難題的那段路
原影片32分鐘
後面他還講了兩件事
一件是他們團隊猜到OpenAI要大公佈了
週一晚上趕在最後一刻
先把自己的一篇論文貼上網
另一件事
他覺得以後這名大概不會再從數學家的腦袋裡長出來了
可是一個點子
從數學家一路傳到一般人的那條長路
還是得有人顧
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多